I want to thank Jared for the
opportunity to be here and to talk about
this specific data said who who's
actually worked with them nest all right
cool
very good and if you go to Wikipedia you
can kind of find out all about it right
you go down way in the footnotes with an
asterisk and you might be able to trace
down the kind of information I'm going
to tell you today which is how did this
data set even come about and in telling
the story Asli creating data sets or all
right so rewind the tape
so I started NIST in 1986 roll back to
the late 80s what do we have going on at
that point in time improvements in
computation and algorithms and there's
rapid advancement in pattern recognition
technologies this is driving signal
processing and image processing and a
key approach that's just caught fire is
this thing called a multi-layer
perceptron an MLP also known as a neural
network does that sound familiar today
hmm really does doesn't it it's kind of
kind of hearing now at that time this
wasn't lost on us covered
Department of Defense was investing a
ton of money and resources into this
automated tartar for targeted mission
but on the civilian side you're a census
that was a shout out earlier to that it
was great the postal service and yes the
IRS they're all looking at how to use
handwriting to automate things like
reading zip codes so we can get the mail
to its proper destination faster
all right so back in the late 80s these
are the type of neural networks that we
were dealing with they often had one
hidden layer so you got this input layer
of your data you got the output layer of
your activation answers in the middle
you do this combinatorial nonlinear
feed-forward and get in it get some sort
of prediction we did a lot of work on
not feeding the actual raw data into
this network at the input layer we would
do classical numerical methods to create
feature vectors that then we would put
in to do the machine learning alright
and oh by the way around 1989 or so Yan
Laocoon showed up at one of the zip code
conferences and said hey I've added a
fourth layer to the bottom it's a
convolutional layer and it'll take the
raw pixels in and start to do something
with it
1989 so fast forward about 2010 Alec's
net comes out and oh my gosh we've
discovered convolutional neural nets
well not necessarily but you can see
that something's gone on here right now
these last three three layers they're
pretty much the same technology in the
prior slide but dealing with the raw
information and pixels to derive to self
derive image features that's what's all
going on in this deep network alright so
that just gives you an idea there's a
lot that isn't new and there's some
things that are new and what's really
driving this is more about the data and
the computational capacity that we have
today
so why NIST okay so back then we had
this key question what is the accuracy
of handprinted character recognition
vendors were selling this to the
government they were running their own
benchmarks on their own data using their
own metrics so how do you know which
numbers to trust and that's where Ness
comes in we help bring objective
measurement to technology and emerging
technology so what do you need to do
some sort of a benchmark you need some
sort of calibrated instrument calibrated
artifact in this case ground truth data
right and so that's why this character
data set actually came into existence
real quick and my story I'd like to talk
to you about the time
it starts in 1990 with the release of
something called special database one we
go out to 1988 well but I thought
eminent was new No
nineteen eight nineteen ninety-eight and
necess introduced and there's all this
NIST work that got us there so I'd like
to talk to you a little bit about that
and then oh by the way there's this data
point out here real recent called EMS
for extended and we'll get there at the
end all right so the under status ed is
born through a carefully designed data
collection using this type of
handwriting sample form in the end
there's about a hundred templates of
this form in the original data set and
it was carefully designed you can see
the digits 0 through 9 written out three
times in order but then you get this set
of variable length fields with a balance
but randomized distribution of those
digits that handled colocation effects
and things like that there's a field
down here of lowercase alphabet and the
uppercase alphabet and for some freeform
text which was just kind of pushing
everything in the day we have people
write out by hand again ask them to
print the preamble to the US
Constitution now quick story we sent out
thousands of these forms through
business return envelopes that come back
to NIST we started getting tens twenties
hundreds we're like oh my gosh we got to
open all these envelopes right so we
borrow a letter opener nota made a
letter opener from our mailroom and a
very overly eager technician grabs a
stack of these envelopes it'll burn okay
they blow open the first envelope those
forms were by folded put into the
envelope so not only did it rip off the
end of the envelope it also severed the
forms and - so anyway always be careful
and don't and trust your valuable data
too
and experienced people things got a
delay that I'm not used to come on there
we go
all right so 1990 we got these we ended
up receiving back 2100 of these
completed forms they were filled out by
census employees they were field data
takers all across the United States so
we had handwriting representation
samples across the the lower lower 48
anyway
this data set was distributed on
something do you know what that is
compact disk read-only memory right
cd-rom right so this was this was new
technology in the day to put that data
out we could get what a gigabyte
gigabyte of data on there or something
so they get the forms were on there the
full scanned images and also the cropped
out fields of the handwriting we scanned
this in at 300 pixels per inch and we
did it in by level black and white and
just to get to this point you know we
had to do that data collection design we
then had to do the form scanning we had
to determine an image format and
compression because images they would
fill up capacity of discs in that day
very quickly we had to create something
called form registrations so we could
look at the image finally find the boxes
on the form to find the characters in
the boxes and then do this field
isolation so that was 1990 then a couple
years go by and we're still working
really really hard and we really special
database 3 this is a collection of that
labeled segmented and labeled characters
that were on all those those handwriting
forms and now we had this collection of
individual character images of digits
lowercase each character centered in 128
128 pixel image to get to this point the
milestones Nina were well we wrote a
character recognizer so he used a lot of
prints or blob coloring a component
analysis and then we had to reconstruct
things like when the top of a 5 that's
not detached or not attached has to be
put back together so a lot of work and
character segmentation and then before
we could send this out we needed the
labels
need the ground truth well we were
pretty clever about how we designed the
form remember on top of the form we told
the writer what the right well maybe
they didn't write what we asked them to
write and then you add automated like
character segment to segmentation to the
whole bit
you now have air and so we had to human
adjudicate all those characters so
here's a quick story how did we do that
right we have hundred thousand couple
are a thousand of these characters well
we had a lab technician didn't have a
grad student sorry we had a lab
technician who was prone to wander and
become distracted and was put under a
performance improvement plan of the
government and he had the wonderful
measured task to sit in a very cold
machine room on a Sun Microsystems
display and what we did is we created a
thumbnail montage of a thousand 24
character images of the same class all
the zeros at once all the ones at once
and the visual aspects of our human
brains you can sit there and go oh my
gosh that is not a zero right and so you
just pluck them out you could reassign
it and we could comb the data that way
and anyway we won't talk about the guys
performance plan review okay so 1992 we
use that data to run a test
remember NIST objective measurements
let's figure out what the accuracy is
for the for the benefit of the
government to run procurements know how
to put in our RFPs the the proper error
rate requirements and things like that
we also processed another 500 forms of
characters in order to do a blind
sequester test set called SD 27 that was
filled out by some high some students
and then fast forward to 1995 we
repeated this whole process and scaled
it up and my colleague Patrick grow
there gets a lot of credit to get us to
this milestone and we have something
called special database 19 these special
databases were put out by NIST in the
public domain free to be used we didn't
put any traceability on it they you know
we knew when people ordered CDs but you
could you could put CD data
cherish saying we didn't have any
protocols on how to use the data but in
the end we had over a hundred and
fourteen hundred thousand segmental
label characters and to get to this
place we also introduced remember that
preamble paragraph at the bottom
I wrote code that could then take the
segmentation infer the reading order use
a dictionary to actually clean up the
classification with with the neural
network classifier and so that is the
special database nineteen that yam
laocoon picked up for M nest this
database this data set is available
today
now all that technology in order to
create this I put together a package
called hsf handwriting sample form
system sis Hsss and this package that's
written in C so you can probably get it
I'm sorry it's not an R but you can get
it you could you could probably port the
code with some work to the modern
compiler but in there is form
registration field isolation form
removal because we would get the
characters and we would segment them out
of the boxes but a lot of times the
characters overlapped with the box
information and so how do you remove and
clean that up
all that's in there neural network based
classification that classifier code
actually contains approaches that are
being used extensively still today with
the deep learning and then fast forward
from 95 to 98 when M nest actually is
first introduced out of all those
characters
Yan laocoon karena court Cortez and
Chris Burgess they carved out 70,000 of
the hand-printed digits balance sets
fifty fifty thousand or sixty thousand
for training ten thousand for testing
but remember I said it was by level by a
black and white image originally
feminist is in gray well that's not real
gray
all right it's a pseudo gray created
through a bike bike cubic interpolation
of the binary images and scaling them
down to
28 by 28 okay and so that is that is M
NIST and now there's something called
e/m mist oh and also that's why the mist
is even in the name so extended m-miss
so st 19 814 hundred thousand characters
only 70,000 were actually put in the
eminence benchmark particularly with the
advent of deep learning convolutional
neural nets at scale the error rates as
many of you know are very very low now
on that Emnes benchmark and it really is
time to raise the bar we're just not
seeing enough air we're not pushing the
algorithms enough to really be
comparatively useful so let's see
Gregory coincide
afshar Jonathan taps in and Andre Van
Schaick they get credit for going back
to the SD 19 and kind of carving out
some new sets you'll see at the bottom
of this table the Emnes set the
preserved for for backward reference and
compatibility but if you've got three
lines up two digits there's a new
reference set out there that has a total
of 280,000 so that the community can
then retrain and start to also generate
benchmark accuracy error rates and and
compare each other to this all right
I think I blew right through this so
what I'd like to leave you with this
some lessons learned and I'll be around
after the break to talk about any of
this first thing producing high quality
ground truth labelled data sets is
costly how many of you have done
labeling a date and created data sets to
run your our our experimentation yeah
it's just a it's just a pain in the butt
but there are things that can help and
as you saw demonstrated here starting
out with a careful data collection
design can be very helpful can save you
a lot down the road
developing a robots toolset and the
domain that you're working in so that
you can use automated techniques to do
labeling a first pass at labeling and
then use human adjudication through
visualization or some other secondary
means in order to try to clean this up
we were able to estimate that through
our validation or authentication
adjudication process we got these label
characters at that scale down to less
than one err in a thousand then another
thing I'd like to leave you with is hang
in there this is what 2018 fiscal year
2019 if you're a Fed so we're talking
about this stuff was you know nineteen
eighteen late 80s early 90s
hang in there because you never know
what's gonna stick my career took me off
into pattern recognition and biometrics
fingerprint face iris recognition things
like that I had no idea there was a
community that was swelling around some
of this SD 19 data I mean this found out
very late in fact where we where we saw
the use of SD 19 in the early 2000s was
you know I am NOT a bot where you have
to go in and validate you're really
someone the characters they show
companies realize they could get hem
print data for free so so that helped
feed that for a while so hang in there
and I can say that the odds of having
something stick increases when your work
in this case data and source code is
made public
all right and then the last thing I'd
like to say is pay it forward because
what goes around comes around
and I know I'm preaching to the choir
here because I think this is definitely
the spirit of this community so Jared
thank you so much it's really the first
time that I know of that there's a real
store full story of them this has that
actually been told thanks for listening
I you've been the guinea pigs or the
unfortunate first time listeners but
again I'll be around at the break thank
you
[Applause]